hey youtubers is Charlie so a couple of
my friends are working on a TV show so I
thought it'd be fun to try and do a
couple of videos for you may have heard
of Beowulf it's gonna be starting next
week in the United States it's hearing
on the Esquire network this is just
gonna be an explainer for what's going
on
most of you probably had to study a
version of Beowulf in high school but
what it is is the oldest living English
poem it's actually written in an old
English which is a different language
from English but you get the idea it was
actually written sometime between the
8th in the 11th century the simple
explanation is that the poem itself is
all about what it means to be a hero
it's one of the original hero's tales
you guys may have heard me talk about
Joseph Campbell's hero of a Thousand
Faces it's all about the hero's journey
most major Hollywood films including the
big superhero films are built on that
hero's journey Beowulf is one of the
original versions of that the TV show is
telling a version of that story just
expanding on the characters it's gonna
be a 13 episode series if you're not
sure when this is gonna be on its
January 23rd that's a Saturday that's
gonna be episode 1 on the Esquire
network usually I miss the time up just
because I watch shows in a bunch of
different time zones but on the Esquire
network it's 10:00 p.m. Eastern Time
9:00 central and if you live in a
different time zone just be sure to
double-check your channel guide so over
the next couple of weeks it's just gonna
be one of my Saturday videos I've kind
of been looking for something to replace
my Saturday videos because dr. who's off
the air I'd say the tone of the show is
pretty close to a bastard executioner
Rome Outlander so if you've been
watching those shows you have a pretty
good feel for the pacing now obviously
it's set in a much different time in a
much different area but you kind of get
the idea
the Beowulf legend itself is actually
Scandinavian so it's actually all
happening way way further north Beowulf
is the protagonist of the series so it
largely follows his perspective but
because the poem itself is so short
they've expanded it we're gonna be
following a lot of other characters
stories that are inside that poem they
posted a short trailer so I'm gonna play
here
this time they need to destroy all of us
who killed him not who but what well
whoever it was
I'll fight off
there are no finer warriors in the
shieldlands Colinas boy got away with
killing
there will be bloodshed doesn't that
just sound familiar if you thought there
was a happy ending to this then you
haven't been paying attention but
Beowulf itself is all about the idea of
the heroic code value systems the
difference between being a good warrior
being a good king and the idea that
following that code doing the right
thing doesn't always lead to the best
possible outcome you know you don't
right off into the sunset on a cloud so
the idea of living by a code is a very
big deal there are a few changes from
the original poem in the poem Beowulf is
one of the Geats he's already a hero
when he meets these new people so he's
kind of like a stranger in a strange
land
but he's this big badass he comes to
help them out in the series he meets
these people from the poem as a small
child and he grows up with them for a
time and then gets banished then comes
back to court and the craziness starts
the craziness that he gets into in the
poem with Grendel in real-world history
they were the Danes so really what the
TV series is doing is just giving him
more history with those Danish
characters but he himself in the poem is
from the Geats which is actually a
different place over here really the
idea is that he's become this big
warrior in his time away he's developed
this code his Warriors code in the codes
going to be tested by the craziness
that's going on with his former family
but it's it's not just the supernatural
aspect with Grendel and his mother
there's a lot of other stuff going on
you know even with a prehistory that
they tell during the first episode and a
lot of that backstory like the great
adventures that he had while he was away
the stuff that happened the reason that
he got banished in the first place
they'll tease that out as the series
goes along no look they wanted it I got
it now back up now it's not as couldn't
Dreyer simply being good and bad and he
makes some decisions which I think
people will find pretty morally
reprehensible
in that respect he is he is very much an
antihero but in that respect as well he
is also very very human if you're ever
gonna be a warrior this is what it's
about the story that we have here it's
set up with stakes are very high right
from the beginning there are so many
different things it's so rich love
family loss and ambition so I think it's
gonna be a lot of fun and it's way more
hardcore than the stuff you'll see on
MTV or any of the other networks you'll
probably recognize at least a couple of
the actors Ciaran brews the protagonist
he's playing Beowulf you probably
remember him from da Vinci's demons if
you've been watching that show William
Hurt is playing Hrothgar another huge
character but what I'm gonna do is I'll
just I'll explain a little bit more
about who all the characters are when I
do my episode 1 video but that's not
gonna air till the 23rd so you guys
still have plenty of time to catch up
there is a dedicated website for the
show right now it's Esquire tv.com slash
Beowulf they have a bunch of interviews
a bunch of behind the scenes stuff so
I'll put a link in the description for
where to find that or you can search
your guide like you're a guide on your
TV for Beowulf that should get you to
where you need but if you do have any
other big questions just leave them in
the comments so we can figure it out as
we go along so hopefully you guys like
it I think it's gonna be a lot of fun
I'm just gonna do a couple videos for it
it'll be a saturday video so be sure to
subscribe to get everything and I will
put some extra links in the description
for where to find the website for the
series they have extra clips and
interviews and stuff there with all the
actors so it's actually pretty cool so
check it out so if you guys are still
confused about what's going on you can
click here that'll take you straight to
the website they have a whole bunch of
stuff there remember episodes are gonna
start next week so I'll just I'll start
posting videos it'll be a Saturday thing
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you